desde hoy los viajeros de argentina
méxico brasil y chile- y de otros 43
países podrán regresar al reino unido-
sin embargo otros 7 países caribeños y
latinoamericanos como colombia perú
ecuador venezuela panamá haití y
república dominicana se mantienen en la
lista roja del gobierno británico es
decir que se puede viajar pero al
regreso se debe hacer una cuarentena de
11 días en un hotel elegido por el
gobierno y cada pasajero debe pagar más
de tres mil cien dólares esta lista roja
ha sido altamente criticada por lo
discriminatoria y porque por ejemplo un
país como brasil que acaba de superar la
barrera de los 600 mil contagios una
cifra récord sólo alcanzada por eeuu fue
excluído pero un país como colombia que
reporta diarios más de mil casos de kobe
19 frente a un país como el reino unido-
que reporta diariamente más de 20 mil
casos para los expertos no tiene ninguna
justificación
el gobierno
y ha justificado esta medida aduciendo
que un país por ejemplo como colombia
presenta algunas variantes especialmente
la mud y hay probabilidades y se
mantienen las fronteras abiertas de que
ésta llegue al reino unido- esta medida
por supuesto ha causado un impacto
emocional entre las personas que no han
podido reunirse las familias que no ha
podido verse desde que empezó la
pandemia y también en el sector
turístico tanto británico como
latinoamericano